prime minister it is good to meet you
and I look forward to our discussion as
we all know the relationship between the
UK and the United States is a very
important one and you are among our
greatest allies and certainly all of us
are here in Munich to discuss many
issues but predominantly Our concern
about Russia's aggression in Ukraine and
our transatlantic community and how it
has risen to meet the needs of
supporting the Ukrainian people and ours
is an enduring relationship and I look
forward to talking with you about the
work that we have done and more
importantly the work that we will
continue to do together so thank you for
that well Madam vice president it is a
great privilege to see you too for the
first time and thank you for your kind
words about the relationship between our
two countries which I completely agree
with and there could be no better
illustration of that than our joint
response to the auto in Ukraine where we
have stood together and led I think the
world in providing steadfast support to
Ukraine so it can defend itself and push
back against Russian aggression and I
know in your speech and my speech we
both agreed that that is the right
strategy and one that we hope everyone
continues to follow so I look forward to
discussing more about that with you in a
moment but also the many other things
that we cooperate so closely on thank
you prime minister
last year on this stage
I warned of the imminent invasion
of Ukraine by Russia
and let us all recall
many at the time wondered how we would
all respond
many wondered
could Russia be stopped
would NATO come together
would NATO break apart
and wood Ukraine be prepared
colleagues today A year later we know
Kiev is still standing Russia is
weakened
the transatlantic Alliance is stronger
than Everest from the starting days of
this unprovoked war
we have witnessed
Russian forces engage in horrendous
atrocities and war crimes
their actions are an assault on our
common values
and attack
on our common Humanity
and let us be clear
Russian forces have pursued a wide
spread
and systemic attack
against a civilian population
gruesome Acts
of murder
torture
rape and deportation
execution style killings
beatings
and electrocution
Russian authorities have forcibly
deported hundreds of thousands of people
from Ukraine to Russia
including children
they have cruelly separated children
from their families in the case of
Russia's actions in Ukraine
we have examined the evidence
we know the legal standards
and there is no doubt
these are crimes against humanity the
United States has formally determined
that Russia has committed
crimes against humanity
and I say
to all those who have perpetrated these
crimes
and to their superiors
who are complicit in these crimes
you will be held
to account